Hey, I'm here with Jesse Toth,
a backend Ruby developer at GitHub.
So Jesse, when I was first reading
through the Ruby documentation when I
was learning to code,
I felt pretty discouraged.
And I'm glad that I didn't give up then,
though, because
otherwise I wouldn't have ended up with
this awesome career in technology.
So, could you share with us a time or
a moment that you felt discouraged or
that maybe you weren't cut out for this?
And how do get through that?
>> Definitely.
I mean, looking at the Ruby docs
myself there's a lot there.
And there's no way to
learn all of it at once.
There are definitely times
where I've been struggling for
almost a whole day to try and
figure out something, that in the end,
it seemed really simple but
I didn't understand it at the time But
I had to struggle through it and
learn different things.
And along the way, I learned
about not just that problem, but
what was underneath that problem.
>> So, when you encounter a problem,
you see it more so
as a challenge to overcome rather
than as a, I messed up, right?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
It can be frustrating to get stuck and
to feel like you don't know, but
once you get pass that then
you've learned something.
And you've added a new
tool to your toolbelt.
>> That's awesome.
We've all got our own personal obstacles
or concerns when learning something new.
What are some of yours?